here's the thing I want to start with uh
a lot of people in the last few years
have gotten comfortable watching movies
at home and Devotion to me is a movie
you want to experience in a movie
theater you want to get off your ass you
want to see this on a huge screen and so
can you both sort of talk about that
that this is a movie theater movie
I'll I'll just jump in in terms of uh
this movie is shot in a format with
Academy award-winning uh DP Eric
measurement uh who won the Oscar for
mank it is shot on IMAX format
um incredible and if you look at the
storytelling within the frame we're
using real airplanes we built an entire
carrier yeah you're looking at these
these these War scenes taking place on
the ground uh huge epic crane moves over
battlefields and you know hundreds and
hundreds of extras we are recreating a
Korean the Korean War a war that hasn't
been put on screen in in decades
um so the the beautiful part of this
story The reason I think this story is
not only pointy but cinematic is that
it's at the heart of it is this this
intimate Story of Friendship and family
and devotion but on a cinematic level we
take a a drama and give it so much scope
so if you do not see this in the theater
you're missing out because there's a lot
to see on camera in this movie yeah
there's also a lot to feel
um theater drama is made for uh the
masses right the way theater came to us
as a species is we would gather together
in large groups to watch it to be
reenactments of marriages of War of of
Journeys and it was important that we
all saw it together to witness and to
take on that that moment of catharsis so
we could all heal and grow and be put in
a mindset that would allow us to
collectively move forward so I would say
do yourself the service of having that
experience that communal experience both
for the visuals but also for uh the
emotional Journey that that this film
offers amen but I also say this is in
terms of Thanksgiving like I was talking
about this with with a lot of my friends
and family who have gone to see the
movie it is appealed to absolutely
everyone if you are going to see a movie
on Thanksgiving yeah this movie appeals
to absolutely everyone everyone exactly
what you're talking about that
collective experience yeah everyone
leads feeling fulfilled and challenged
and inspired in the same way with
different points of view and different
perspectives uh and I just think that's
such a rare thing in movies so please go
see it in the largest format possible
please for both of you I I am a fan of
both of your work and I'm curious when
you are making a movie like this on what
day of the shoot are you actually
feeling comfortable in the role or are
you sort of never comfortable or are you
confident on day one I'm just sort of
curious about your mindset when you're
inhabiting real people and you know what
I mean I'll I'm just gonna quote
Jonathan Majors on this every day is a
big day every day's a big day yeah uh
and that's one thing that on a movie
like this when you approach pictures
like this who there is so much I would
say pressure to to do their story right
um You can't take your foot off the gas
you know you can't quit and you can't
have a day off
um and that's one thing that having
someone like this across from you at
every stage of this thing gives you so
much confidence because on this movie I
I met Jonathan Majors uh and approached
him to play Jesse Brown
I
met on set Jesse Brown every day
um and that's a beautiful thing to feel
that uh to feel the spirit of the man
he's embodying every day Jonathan Majors
never had one day off never had one
moment off it's a it's a it's an
incredible thing to watch and that's
another thing I'll challenge everybody
to go see this movie is it's a truly
transformative experience for me to
watch someone I know so well that I'm so
comfortable with that I love Jonathan
Majors but to watch this movie and watch
it over and over and see Jesse Brown is
is truly
uh just the most that's that's why you
go to the movies to see
performances like this and and and to
see performances like this and a scope
uh like this so anyway I'm go see it
Jesus uh I'm just go I'm just gonna just
gonna say that uh uh Tom hudner and
Glenn Powell are the two uh individuals
that I met maybe three years ago uh
Glenn held on to that Spirit of him
brought him to work and pitched me the
opportunity of Jesse Brown with that
ethos with that uh uh point of view and
when we were shooting it
um he was present and he had he you you
were with it for five years six years
yes yeah yeah six years now you know so
one of the things I always you know uh
aab always assume Brilliance right
always assuming so whatever he brought
in I thought
that's it right that's perfect I think
I've said that to you the same is
perfect even if it goes all straight
it's perfect we need this to get to that
you know and there was no one I have
felt uh so comfortable uh with
with the mess of it with the complexity
of it you know and so from the beginning
uh I I I have a certain processes so yes
like from the beginning from the second
I hit Georgia I was in Jesse Brown's
world and and trying to conjure his
psyche um and that was only supported by
a coming to you know the the tarmac in
meeting you know Tom hudner uh Glenn
Powell you know
um so yeah so that's the question I mean
uh humbly you know we we attempted to be
in it you know uh day one
um yeah and that donated to stop I'm
just gonna say gentlemen it's a pleasure
congrats on the movie I really hope it's
a huge hit
thank you Senator thanks Steve cool have
a great day